in what has been considered one of the
best Star Wars stories told since the
original trilogy Andor is filled with
the dark reality of what it takes to
start a rebellion the story's ending is
as complex as the characters it portrays
warning spoilers ahead
it seems only right that and or would
end on the same planet where it begins
Cassian andor's Homeworld of ferrics the
people of ferricks have been suffering
under Imperial rule all season so it's
powerful that they would be the ones to
rise up in symbolic resistance in the
season finale after seeing all the
characters spread across the Galaxy for
most of season one it's fun to watch
them all gather on pharynx for the
funeral of cassian's adoptive mother
Marva Imperials and Rebels alike come
out in the hopes of catching Cassian but
his friends and family on pharynx have
other plans after playing a recording of
marva's final words a stirring speech
telling her people to fight back the
assembled crowd storms the barricades
showing that they'll no longer sit
quietly under the boot of fascism it's
not entirely clear how planned out this
Revolt was but the implication is that
ferrics came prepared we see Wilman Pack
building pipe bombs the night before
readying his retribution for the killing
of his father and when the funeral
procession comes it comes much earlier
than the Empire expected and with more
people ready for a fight
Martha and or dies unceremoniously at
the beginning of Andor episode 11. off
screen and without any meaningful final
words but if you thought that was the
last you'd see of fionasha's impeccable
performance you were wrong Marva leaves
behind a lasting Legacy of resistance
telling the citizens of ferrics to rise
up and fight and encouraging her son to
become the hero she always knew he could
be when the Imperial officer tries to
silence her hologram by throwing his
coat over it the message plays on
undeterred it seems it's not so easy to
put out a fire once it's been licked her
last words ring like a concise slogan
over the entire show
the empire
though many are killed in the battle
that breaks out we understand that their
sacrifices are meaningful carcinemic
writes in his Manifesto remember that
the frontier of the Rebellion is
everywhere and even the smallest Act of
insurrection pushes our lines forward
we're told that the dead of ferrics are
burned their ashes baked into bricks and
those bricks put into the city's walls
but Marvis brick becomes a literal
weapon with Brasso using its strike to
first blow in her funeral Uprising
nemec's words likewise become the fuel
for cassium to commit to the cause
Against All Odds several of the ferric's
characters make it out at the end of
andor's season 1. Shipyard hand pegler
gets vessel ready and fueled up for
Brasso wolman b2emo and Jesse another
hint that the whole Revolt was
premeditated what the crew couldn't have
fully planned on however with cassian's
return and successful Rescue of Bix
Colleen of course Cassian doesn't come
back to ferrics to fight he comes to
complete bits of Unfinished Business
seeing Marvel laid to rest and rescuing
picks he does both of those things and
helps ensure that the ferric's gang gets
away safely where they'll go and how
safe they'll be is unclear but given the
abject chaos of the Revolt they have a
decent chance at flying under the
Empire's radar hopefully with a bit of
Peace Bix can recover from the
deplorable torture perpetrated against
her
it's a testament to Cassie and Edward's
skill that he evades every one of the
half dozen people who come to capture or
kill him on pharynx he clocks Lutheran
in the crowd early on and puts two and
two together realizing that the rebel
leader means to eliminate him to tie up
Loose Ends Cassian seeks out luthan's
ship parked in the same spot they
escaped from in episode 3 and waits for
him to return you came here to kill me
didn't you
it'll make it easy
then Cassian hits him with the
unexpected I will now having
intentionally left his blaster for
Lutheran to take Cassian gives him an
ultimatum kill me
or take me in it's a dramatic move and
the line on which and or season 1 ends
but it's a necessary one to prove
cassian's Newfound dedication to the
Rebellion when the two men last spoke he
was little more than a common Rogue a
man with potential but he vocally
opposed joining any organized resistance
movement to convince luzen of how
dedicated he's become after his
experiences on narquita 5 he puts his
very life in Luther's hands this is a
huge step on cassian's past becoming the
man we meet in Rogue one and it sets up
a ton of potential for Andor season 2.
one of the most interesting
relationships in and or season 1
develops between serial Karn and
dedramiro Dedra is a rising star in the
Imperial Security Bureau who's consumed
with rooting out Rebels trying
experimental torture techniques and
other unsightly Hobbies Cyril is a
single-minded bureaucrat with his own
vision of Justice together they're a
match made in the darkest corners of the
Empire so it's not a surprise when Cyril
saves deja's life in the season finale
before the fighting on ferric's Dedra
makes it very clear to Cyril that she
wants nothing to do with him
understandable after he stalks her to
her place of work and declares his love
for her in the middle of the street but
what do you do with a guy like that
after he pulls you out of a mob that's
about to tear you to pieces where these
two go next is anyone's guess but it
should be impossible to look away from
it's hard to imagine Cyril's heroics
have really made him any more enticing
to Dedra will they become an evil power
couple or a human Time Bomb we can't
wait to find out
in a season filled with anxious people
mon mothma may be the most anxious of
all and for good reason faced with the
prospect of the Empire discovering she's
secretly funding the Rebellion mon makes
an impossible Choice she agrees to
introduce her teenage daughter leida to
the son of high-profile loan shark davo
skalden in a chandrillan custom that
will almost surely lead to marriage in
exchange Dava will make all of Mon's
accounting troubles go away protecting
her from the prying eyes of the Empire
even the latest seems to love the old
Central and traditions this is a hard
moment to watch Monde effectively sells
her daughter for the good of the
Rebellion we also see mon accusing her
husband Perrin of gambling which he
denies their driver eavesdrops on the
conversation and later reports to the
ISB since mon knows her driver is a spy
and since parent appears to be telling
the truth this is almost certainly part
of her plan her goal appears to be
planting a false explanation for the
inconsistencies in her family accounts
that will divert attention away from the
rebel alien she's become quite Adept at
covering her tracks but at what cost
by the end of Andor season 1 mon mothma
seems to have things pretty under
control on her end lose it on the other
hand is on the brink of having his cover
fully blown after narrowly escaping from
an Imperial cruiser at the end of
episode 11 he goes straight to ferrics
this leaves his course on shop fully in
the hands of his assistant Claire who at
times seems like she might be the one
really running the show though the
Empire hasn't seen luton's face yet they
have identified his ship the fondor
which is a custom job as such he might
need to be a bit more careful if he does
return to Coruscant there's also the
fact that his ISB mole Lonnie seems to
be getting on dead Ramiro's bad side
given how good Deedra is at her job this
could be big trouble for Lutheran later
on for now though he's still a free man
two more characters who managed to make
it out of and or season one alive are
Val sarza and syndicaz who reunite on
ferrics just in time to completely Miss
Cassian and get out amid the chaos while
there's clearly real love between the
two of them it's also apparent that
they're in very different places Vel is
a rich girl who threw her old life away
to join the Rebellion on the other hand
cinta is someone whose entire family was
wiped out by Stormtroopers as a result
cinta is a die-hard radical someone who
never thinks twice about risking
everything for the cause I told you up
front the struggle will always come
first we take what's left
Vel has more reservations and spends a
lot of time thinking about what life
could be like if they didn't have to
fight will the demands of Revolution
tear Val and Center apart only time will
tell
Vel and Sinta aren't the only Rebel
agents who head out for Parts Unknown at
the end of Andor season one Bruce Scott
melshi says goodbye to Cassian on Nemos
at the end of episode 11 telling him
they need to split up to increase their
chances of survival melshi seems enliven
to tell the story of what happened on
narkina 5. he wants the Galaxy to know
how the Empire is making up prison
sentences to create an endless labor
pool if you've seen Rogue one you'll
know that melshi's passion makes him a
loyal soldier of the Rebel Alliance
later on he fights alongside Cassian on
scarif at the end of Rogue one so it's
likely that he'll pop up again in Andor
season 2. the Revolt of narkina 5
ultimately becomes a Flashpoint moment
for the larger show revealing house
sacrifice and mass mobilization can
carry the downshot into victory over
their oppressors it's possible that more
escapees from the narkina 5 Prison Break
could join the rebel cause later on as
well though his heartbreaking
declaration in episode 10 that he can't
swim suggests a grim fate kinoloi could
still be alive we never see him die and
the fates of the other escaped prisoners
are left ambiguous one thinks for sure
though with the Empire becoming more
oppressive than ever the Rebellion
should have an ample supply of new
recruits going forward
series Creator Tony Gilroy has said that
he didn't write Andor to be a political
think piece he prioritized the story and
the characters and that Focus shows
however it's hard to write a grounded
narrative about Rebels rising up against
a fascist regime and not pick up some
larger philosophy along the way by the
end of the finale season one almost
reads like a god book on how to build
Revolution right down to the stirring
Manifesto nemec writes in his political
Treatise freedom is a pure idea it
occurs spontaneously and without
instruction random acts of insurrection
are occurring constantly throughout the
Galaxy there are whole armies battalions
that have no idea they've already
enlisted in the cause this is the idea
that the season finale brings to the
Forefront that no regime no matter how
powerful can stand up to the strength of
the people if they all join forces nemec
insists that the rich and Powerful few
are no match for the impassioned many
echoing another Manifesto from our our
own world quite clearly he also writes
requires constant effort it breaks it
leaks
Authority is brittle
when the people of Ferrick stand unified
against their oppressors their enemies
break indeed
and or season one does a lot to make the
Empire scary again it shows the coldness
of Imperial rule the dehumanization and
the way that local populations are
scattered weakened and stripped of their
Traditions it demonstrates the cruelty
of the Empire's hard-fisted military
rule and in doing so evokes the
atrocities committed by empires in real
world history it's no secret that George
Lucas largely based Palpatine's
fictional regime on both the British
Empire and American imperialism of the
20th century and or returns that
inspiration to the Forefront and the
effect is powerful for all it's might
however the Empire and Andor still makes
many mistakes Princess Leia's words to
Grandma Tarkin ring like an overture
over the whole show the more you tighten
your grip talk the more star systems
will slip through your fingers
if the Empire didn't push such extreme
prison sentences if they didn't double
down on Military occupations if they
didn't insist on being so extreme in
their dominance then maybe they would
have lasted longer but by increasing
their tactics to such violent degrees
they push the citizens of the galaxy to
the point of desperation what's the only
thing left to do when a normal life
becomes impossible to live fight and
that's exactly what happens
nemix Manifesto speaks powerful truths
about the struggle against the empire
Every Act of insurrection matters and
that freedom is always worth fighting
for however Andor also emphasizes that
such a revolution requires sacrifices
throughout season one we see nearly
every character give up something in the
interest of the greater good Cassian
sees Bix tortured and pharynx occupied
as a result of his actions mon mothma
risks the safety and stability of her
own family nemec tarmin Lieutenant Gorn
and countless prisoners from narkina 5
give their lives for the cause of
freedom but perhaps the most memorable
commentary on sacrifice comes at the end
of Andor episode 10 in a monologue from
Lutheran calm kindness kinship love I
burn my decency for someone else's
future I burn my life to make a sunrise
that I know I'll never see it's a
powerful moment that resonates through
the remainder of the season in a
franchise is that's historically been
about heroes doing the right thing Andor
is about the dark violent and difficult
things that are necessary to defeat an
Empire so what do I sacrifice
[Music]
everything
themes of sacrifice and questionable
morality permeate Andor they underscore
the dark time in which the show is set a
time when desperation not ethics or
altruism is the driving force in the
Rebellion Lutheran's conversations with
saw Guerrera and mon mothma show just
how divided the existing Rebels are and
how afraid they are to take larger steps
the best way to sum up this era of the
Rebellion might be the fact that no one
ever utters the slogan of the Rebel
Alliance May the force be with you in
the original Star Wars Trilogy the force
is frequently invoked by Rebel leaders
it's a rallying cry an optimistic
invocation of their cause might be a
righteous one but during the era of
Andor there is no such optimism no such
reverence as the story of the show
continues in season two we'll likely see
the Rebellion transform into the one
scene in the original films in Rogue one
generso uses hope as rallying cry for
Cassian and the other Rebels and it
seems like they've almost forgotten the
meaning of the word now we see the
reasons why hard dirty work is necessary
to get to a place where hope can Thrive
and or seems to say and that work is far
from done at the end of season one
in a Star Wars show that issues Easter
eggs and cameos it might be surprising
to learn that Andor actually has a
post-credits scene if you watch through
to the end of the season finale you'll
be treated to a grim glimpse of what
lies in store for Cassian and the
Rebellion a close-up shot shows droids
of some sort assembling what appears to
be a massive plate or dish of some kind
look closely and you'll recognize the
connector pieces they're installing as
the same device as the prisoners of
narkina 5 were forced to build day after
day the camera then zooms out to reveal
that the thing being constructed is part
of the in progress Death Star
specifically the super laser itself the
fact that Cassian was forced to help
build the very thing that would
ultimately kill him is dark but there's
also a Triumph in remembering that he
gets the last laugh by successfully
stealing the Death Star plans with Jin
he ensures the station's destruction
there's a nice symmetry in tying these
disparate plot lines together and that
intentionality will surely remain in
Andor season 2. and or season 2 is
already on the way with Tony Gilroy
telling collider in early November 2022
that production will begin on November
21st two days before the season one
finale dropped on Disney plus that means
things are already in motion which is
great news for fans unfortunately we may
be waiting a while before Andor season 2
premieres speaking with the rap in
September 2022 Gilroy said that
production for season 2 won't end until
August 2023 and that post-production
could take as long as another whole year
afterward that would mean a premiere
date sometime in the late summer or
early fall of 2024 at the earliest as
for what Andor season 2 might look like
we already have a lot of clues in an
interview with rolling stone Gilroy
discussed how season two will cover the
remaining four years leading up to Rogue
one saying that the season will start
with a one-year time Jump the next four
years are not about becoming a
revolutionary they're about learning to
be a leader and how difficult it is to
put the alliance together and what
happens to people who are the original
gangsters versus The Establishment and a
lot of different other issues given the
Way season 1 ends that makes a lot of
sense the showrunner added really the
second half is about what does time do
to these people people grow up and
people get tired and people betray each
other and people change their minds and
people get weak and people get crazy